a good start is very important right now
even the threes are contested they're
not getting an easy shot there's one
this has got to go down yes a great
pickup out of LSU here's Harden again
with the three now the Rockets at the
school harden great move that was pretty
decisive in three run by the Houston
Rockets timeout Minnesota art and
three-point line Jeff Green in the
corner will wait for hard to shoot it
and he hits it there you go
goes cross-court and Alessa comes right
back steals it Jim Hardin alaya
goodbye Russell Westbrook previous
possession Russell Westbrook's all the
way to the basket misses another luck
yeah I'm down there
Pete Jagger the steel press it slams it
home PJ Tucker playing a whale of a game
tonight
bet he missed the free throw and his
tipped away covington gets it up to
russell with the hustle
[Applause]
the Rockets back here tonight well
that's an 8.5 on the Richter Martin's
got Russell in front of it trying to
drive on him he'll take the three all
right part not the bench and joins a
party on the outfits are you all those
double teams of Covington gets out of
there Artie with a long
[Applause]
the whole summer to work on things so
watch out for the Timberwolves next
season back on the Westbrook freeway
and here's DeAngelo Russell getting
beats who's not a very good one-on-one
player Westbrook just goes by him and
hammers it down explosiveness of
Westbrook has gotten us to give up all
the way back to harden down with six on
the shot
[Applause]